The original idea behind MyFC was to see if a large group of football fans...
...could run a football club better than a millionaire, billionaire owner.
And do the Roman Abramovich thing, come in and...
..."Can we, as a collective, run a football club in a better way for the fans?"
The guy who had the idea was a guy called Will Brooks and he was a journalist.
And that is how he sold his vision, that "Can the fans run a football club?"
He got some sponsorship money from Electronic Arts,...
...a video game company and sports company.
And put this idea together and sold it on the Internet,...
...and got interest from 50,000 people,...
...just expressing an interest and they would like to be involved.
And originally 33,000 people signed up...
...and put their money where their mouth was and joined up.
They paid 35 pounds each, with a proportion of that going to running the society...
...and the large bulk of that going straight to the football club.
The club was purchased for around somewhere between one million and 1.5 million pounds,...
...and that pretty much ate up all of the subscription money for that first year.
Members renew on an annual basis.
Most of the money went to buying the club.
We made a lot of improvements in a short space of time,...
...buying new training equipment for the players...
...and sorted out a new kit deal, things like that.
The club went on a fantastic Cup run.
They made it all the way to the Wembley and won the FA Trophy.